[Musique]
bonsoir les enfants
écoutez pas tout mais qui a team nours
vous l'entendez pas pleurer mais non je
suis certains clients un bébé qui pleure
pauvre petit peu je descends voir si je
le trouve europe hop hop hop hop hop hop
hop hop
[Musique]
[Rires]
eh
bien puisque c'est comme ça aof -
mademoiselle k frais voilà
un sport
bien public il pleut rice les caprices
qui fait des caprices mais alors match
les meilleurs coins aux petites tapes
russe
allons où es tu cap russes
tu vas se fera par une fessée à ce grand
ses filles avec leur poupée que fais-tu
courjault je prépare mon lit je me
couche tôt je suis raisonnable mois
n'est ce pas juliette à
la
bonne nuit tout le monde
au même
la voilà cette paisible
sa mère qu'il a grondé alors là du
chagrin
je remercie nicolas tu m'as pas
conseillant des mes caprices et ma fille
y voir un heureux le jour du fis il faut
être raisonnable comme cornichons c'est
le moment de lui où il y
avoue tron
[Musique]
je suis la marchande
stable la journée est finie il faut être
raisonnable
c'est le moment d'aller au lit
[Musique]
tous les jours sur mon nuage
nous nous viens avec moi et nous partons
en voyage
dans le ciel par dessus les toits
[Musique]
je n'ai pas d'autre bagages
qu'un niveau
enchanté et du haut de mon nuage
je serai maumont sable doré
[Musique]
bonsoir les enfants du monde
à demain bonne nuit
moi je continue ma ronde
ont nui à tous les motifs au 9e nuit à
tous les petits
[Musique]